der fall maddie mccann wer weiß ob er
jemals aufgeklärt wird jetzt eine
erneute wendung und zwar im zusammenhang
mit dem hauptverdächtigen dem deutschen
christian brückner es geht um eine narbe
er wird verdächtigt die kleine maddie
2007 in portugal entführt und ermordet
zu haben er sitzt gerade eine
siebenjährige freiheitsstrafe wegen
vergewaltigung ab er soll nun wegen
einer weiteren vergewaltigung erneut
angeklagt werden es droht lebenslange
sicherheitsverwahrung auch ohne eine
verurteilung im fall maddie doch nun
könnte die erneute anklage gegen
christian brückner scheitern wegen einer
markanten körperlichen auffälligkeit
sollte es sich bewahrheiten dass herr
brückner dieses merkmal nicht aufweist
so müsste er als täter ausgeschlossen
werden
rückblick im zuge der maddie
ermittlungen gehen bka und
staatsanwaltschaft braunschweig
hinweisen zu drei weiteren ungeklärten
straftaten nach mit denen brückner in
verbindung gebracht wird
2004 soll brückner demnach die 27
jährige hazel be in portugal in ihrem
appartement vergewaltigt haben die tat
wie es ähnlichkeiten zur vergewaltigung
der us-amerikanerin dnm 2005 auf wegen
der brückner derzeit in oldenburg in
haft sitzt in der berichterstattung zu
diesem fall waren hazel die details der
tat aufgefallen die ihrem eigenen
martyrium ähneln es hat mich umgehauen
als ich las wir 2005 eine frau
angegriffen hatte sowohl die taktik als
auch die art und weise die werkzeuge die
ja bei sich hatte wie gut er es geplant
hatte
hazel be sagte bei der polizei aus ihr
angreifer habe englisch mit deutschen
akzent gesprochen sei etwa 1 meter 80
groß gewesen und habe eine sturmhaube
getragen
aber ich konnte sehen dass der blonde
augenbrauen und stechen blaue augen
hatte der vergewaltiger habe ein messer
dabei gehabt kondome benutzt und die tat
gefilmt doch nun könnte die anklage
wackeln wegen einer markanten
körperlichen auffälligkeit bei der
irischen polizei gab haensel beat nach
bild-informationen an der täter habe am
rechten oberschenkel eine große
kreuzförmige narbe gehabt genau das
könnte für die ankläger in braunschweig
zum problem werden bild weiß brückner
hat am rechten oberschenkel keine narbe
dies ist insofern interessant als dass
die ermittlungsbehörden sicher sind dass
ein und derselbe täter die 72 jährige us
amerikanerin und hazel b vergewaltigt
hat möchte die staatsanwaltschaft das
urteil des lg braunschweig nicht infrage
stellen wäre zwingend die jetzige
bewertung zu revidieren
nach bild informationen hat der
verdächtige bereits einer
erkennungsdienstlichen behandlung
zugestimmt in dieser wird offiziell
festgestellt ob er über eine solch
markante narbe verfügt die
staatsanwaltschaft braunschweig äußert
sich nicht zu den details der
ermittlungen
und bei uns im studio sky fällt aus der
seit jahren über den fall berichtet da
drin ist in dem stoff bekommen anderer
reporter in deutschland hat das alles
auswirkungen auch auf den fall maddie
das ist ja das was uns am meisten
interessiert diese neuen entwicklungen
haben auf den fall maddie direkt keine
auswirkungen es könnte sich aber auch
die haftstrafe des verdächtigen
niederschlagen er sitzt ja gerade für 7
und 7 jahre wegen vergewaltigung ein
sollte diese neue anklage erhoben werden
und sollte die vom gericht zugelassen
werden sollte christian brückner
daraufhin verurteilt werden wegen
vergewaltigung dann ist sehr
wahrscheinlich dass sicherungsverwahrung
verhängt wird das bedeutet dass er nicht
mehr aus dem knast raus kommt unabhängig
davon ob er jemals für den fall maddie
angeklagten drin nicht
das ist jetzt fast zwei jahre her glaube
ich dass anklage erhoben dass das eher
ermittelt wurde wegen wegen im
zusammenhang mit fall maddie es gibt
aber immer noch keine ausreichenden
beweise offenbar gegen brückner warum
dauert das so lange ermittelt wird ja
schon deutlich länger gegen ihn es ist
halt seit zwei jahren erst bekannt dass
er in den fokus der ermittler gerückt
ist und zwar weil die ermittler damals
also bka und staatsanwaltschaft
braunschweig an die öffentlichkeit
gegangen sind und gesagt haben wir sind
bis zu diesem punkt gekommen aber uns
fehlt da noch was deswegen müssen wir
jetzt die öffentlichkeit fragen könnt
ihr uns helfen wer hat was gesehen wer
etwas erlebt gesucht wird ja immer noch
der der der mensch mit dem christian
brückner abtaten telefoniert haben soll
eine möglicherweise
belegen könnte dass er sich am tatort
aufgehalten hat diese personen haben die
ermittler offenbar noch nicht gefunden
nun gibt es zwei erklärungen dafür warum
nichts passiert erstens wahrscheinlich
fehlt das letzte puzzleteil noch mit dem
man ihn auch im fall maddie anklagen
könnte
zweitens sie müssen nicht zu potte
kommen die ermittler haben zeit sie
wissen wo christian brückner ist er
sitzt in haft und das auch noch
mindestens viereinhalb jahre dh wann
immer sie ihn
irgendwo anklagen wollen wann immer sie
in seiner habhaft werden wollen sie
wissen wo ist in der jva rottenburg wie
geht's weiter in diesem wirklich
kompliziert das ist hochinteressant ich
habe lange gesagt ich bin g fest davon
aus dass jetzt die anklage folgt und
zwar im fall hesl be und in zwei
weiteren
straftatbeständen die im rahmen der
ermittlungen auf geblockt sind da geht
es um sexuellen missbrauch von kindern
jetzt mit dieser neuen entwicklung mit
dieser nabel die hazel be an ihrem
peiniger gesehen habe da bin ich
plötzlich nicht mehr so sicher ob diese
anklage erhoben wird wenn doch dann bin
ich sehr gespannt wie die ankläger
dieses faktum argumentieren wollen das
hazel wie diesen habe gesehen hat und
christian brückner keine hat da fällt
aus danke